Also this
morning, the Department of Justice
has now
launched an investigation
into the leak of Pentagon documents
that were posted online.
U.S.
officials have confirmed
that some of the documents are authentic.
The leak poses a serious risk
to relationships with U.S.
allies and military options in Ukraine,
but there is also a concern from Ukraine.
The documents may have been altered
or may be part
of a misinformation campaign.
For perspective on this,
joining us now is retired U.S.
Army Major Mike Lyons.
I mean, this is astounding
because what these documents show, one
is, as The New York Times put it,
that the U.S.
has basically penetrated
every Russian security
apparatus, has great insight into it.
But as David Sanger
writes in The New York Times today,
you know,
this is a disclosure
because this fall out in real time,
because some of these documents
aren't even 40 days old.
So you can actually see what they know
right now
about what's happening in Ukraine.
Yeah, that's right.
I'm having a hard time
getting my head around this.
I mean,
if there's 50 classified
documents, there's 50 separate stories
that are going to impact on the ground
in Ukraine right now.
The fact that they gave away their air
defense platforms
and where those locations,
where they affect troop movements,
they're talking about artillery rounds.
We all know that Ukraine
is running out of artillery.
So the this level of of breach
is significant.
And the fact that
we've kind of asleep at the switch,
we had indications
it was going on the past few months.
We've got to do a better job
monitoring these sites,
these discord sites
that have this kind of information
out there.
It came from the highest levels
of our government,
the Joint Staff,
these documents, they were
they were removed,
obviously, from a briefing
and there were pictures
of these presentations.
So so again,
the damage assessment,
I still think is going on
and it's very significant.
And now all these holes
are likely getting close up.
It's going to cause significant
trust issues between us and Ukraine.
But it does put into
perspective, don't you think, the story
that we've been covering
about all of these classified documents
that are ending up,
you know, at personal residences
and so forth,
just the danger that this poses.
Correct.
It does, Don.
It's not just overclassification.
This is serious stuff.
I mean, this is know
things get over
classified based on
what might embarrass things
within our country.
This has national security
implications on the ground,
signals intelligence, SIGINT,
and so to speak.
It shows us eavesdropping on our allies.
It speaks to the fact that humans, now
human intelligence
sources, could be burned on the ground
people could be
lives are at stake now
with this kind of stuff.
I mean, Kayla makes such a good point
about like real time
right now, information
about Ukraine, etc..
But at the same time,
what was also included
in the reporting from the Times over
the weekend is sensitive
briefing slides on China
and sort of
the entire Indo-Pacific military theater,
the Middle East, terrorism.
It goes so far,
even beyond the current conflict.
I mean, considering relations with what
China and Taiwan look look
what's happening right now. Yeah.
The intelligence agencies
now have got to focus on this
to close
gaps, mitigate risk,
figure out what the damage is with regard
to this disinformation,
taking our eye off the ball
and what's happening in the Pacific.
China Russia could use this
against our Democratic
allies and say, look,
why should you trust the United States?
You're going to give them information.
Some US information
came from other countries.
It had certain classifications
that only certain other countries
had New Zealand, Australia,
not even normal allies, so to speak.
So this is a significant breach
up there with Snowden, WikiLeaks.
With regard,
I hope we're closing ranks pretty quickly
to figure out what happened.
And the point that David Sanger
makes with Snowden is those were
things were three years old.
And this is because of how new this is,
you know,
eavesdropping on allies,
spying on allies, not exactly a surprise.
Everyone knows it. Everyone does it.
But it's the idea
that it's put out in the forefront
can cause tension in those relationships.
What I was most struck
by was what they said
about what's happening in Israel.
And there was essentially this allegation
it was intelligence
that Mossad
is basically the spy chiefs in Israel
had helped foment
the protests that we've all play out
that we've been covering here every day
when it comes to the judicial reform
that's happening in Israel.
Yeah, it gets to the reason
why these documents were released.
You know, did
someone have this level of intellect
that recognize
that that would cause
that kind of a problem?
But again, that came from
signals intelligence,
signals operations,
eavesdropping, so to speak.
But whether or not the United States had
any say
in that really remains to be seen.
But but
the person who released this information
clearly wanted to hurt the US,
Israel relations
with that kind of breach. Yeah.
And just our allies
relationships, as you said, it's
not surprising
that everybody spies on everyone,
but still it's not out there for everyone
to read.
Well, and remember,
whenever it was reported about,
you know,
with Merkel
when she was the German chancellor
and it caused a huge rift
with the Obama White House.
Yeah, just amazing.
I mean, we'll continue to see where
this investigation goes.
Thank you
for stating the significance of it
this morning. Thanks my clients.